ucrania ha podido este viernes continuar
con las exportaciones de maíz y cereales
que fueron bloqueadas en sus puertos
después de la invasión rusa en febrero
de este 2010 y 2 ucrania podido empezar
a hacerlo desde la semana pasada gracias
al acuerdo que llegaron hace casi tres
semanas en estambul con ucrania rusia y
también la mediación de turquía y
naciones unidas para permitir las
exportaciones de un trigo que se había
bloqueado en los puertos soberanos la
semana pasada salió el primer barco y
hoy han salido tres más uno en dirección
a turquía y los otros dos
respectivamente en dirección a irlanda y
el reino unido- sin embargo los tres
están ahora viajando el mar negro
conjuntamente llegarán conjuntamente a
estambul donde el contenido de estos
barcos será investigado por el centro de
coordinación conjunto establecido según
este pacto en estambul una vez los
investigadores se cercioren que el
contenido de estos barcos es únicamente
maíz e cereales podrán continuar su
trayecto según ha explicado el ministro
de infraestructuras de ucrania espera a
ucrania que el volumen de cargueros y de
navíos que pueda salir de sus puertos
mensualmente a partir de ahora sea de en
torno a unos 100 cargueros por mes